just minus the whiteness as Rebecca is a
vehicle for this Movement we say
whiteness is really bad for
representation and queer people this
this is really wild this was going uh
viral over the weekend as well this is
from a National High School debate that
took place on zoom and and you are you
might fall out of your chairs on this
one if you just watch how they have
broken National High School debates
these are supposed to be the brightest
kids debating the most important things
in a decent honorable respectful way and
just watch the way this thing evolves
they have a white debat on their team
which inherently means they have more
whiteness than us we obviously know that
JJ is not white it's pretty obvious go
down onto our pick we give you three
warrants why we subsume all of their
protests and affirm their protest in a
pick what it means is you are furthering
their cause just minus the whiteness as
Rebecca is a vehicle for this Movement
we say whiteness is really bad for
representation in queer people and it's
a bad form of furthering this protest
the best way to further the protest is
to vote for our pick and to affirm it
but minus the whiteness they say that
we're taking over JJ's labor but first
this is a new response if they read this
response before we probably would have
read a capc about how you can't like use
labor across identity lines that's a
really bad thing to do second how PS
work is you affirm their protest we're
not taking over their labor it's just a
technicality of debate then they say
that it's trans exclusion no couple
responses that they dropped from Sanji
one our constructive speech was about
personal experiences about our identity
we are not comfortable discussing our
sexuality on a live stream with 130
people second we say that like um them
telling us how we should represent our
advocacy feeds into our link about
racism because a white person someone on
a white team should never be telling two
women of color how they should be
furthering their advocacy that's an
independent linking to our whiteness
argument that gets dropped you can drop
them right now they say we should have
read things about about the Hall of
Shame it's an identity K we are not
trans Debaters we don't don't want to do
that also they don't put anything about
women of color or queer women of color
in their case which means they also link
it to the exclusion there's no
independent offense off of this then at
the bottom all these stuff about the
Louisville project their racist rhetoric
and using the black labor as a way to
further their advocacy inherently racist
as and independent reasons drop them
they say JJ wrote the argument but no
Rebecca is a ble of the movement you
should never use a white person who's
saying the Louisville project and using
as an example of their advocacy in order
to further a movement them using black
suffering to advance at the tournament
is just a bad thing to do then they say
that um that it's just an example a
white person just shouldn't use a black
person suffering as an example of their
advocacy that's inherently a racist
thing to do and it's too late to respond
to this argument by focus and it's the
largest dropped argument there's also
another dropped argument that links into
racism about how they're telling us how
to represent our advocacy whitness is
bad for queer people I'm GNA I you know
what someone find me a gay white guy and
I'm going to find out what's what on
that one um the hysteria the over
emotion all of the stuff right and that
poor girl Rebecca I'm with you Rebecca
can we send Rebecca something let's find
if anyone can get us in touch with
Rebecca like find out what Rebecca likes
I I'll get Rebecca a little something
for having to listen to that harping
lunatic but again I have some sympathy
for these young people because the
entire system did it to
them